the rules and the codes have been
rewritten behind closed doors such that
almost all sex can be charged as
something criminal it reinforces a
traditional stem identity that sees
women as needing protection sees women
sexuality as something that's
endangering to them hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason and today we're
talking about Laura Kipnis she is a
professor at Northwestern does film and
journalism and is the author of the
fantastic new book unwanted advances
sexual paranoia comes to campus Laura
thanks for talking to us thank you hi
this book it grows out of your 2015 kind
of Inquisition for an article you read
in The Chronicle of Higher Education of
all places that some of your students
said created a hostile workplace or like
invaded their safe space the controlling
metaphors in your book are McCarthyism
satanic ritual child abuse witch trials
summarize your case and while you're
thinking about it in these terms okay
just to a slight correction it wasn't my
student who brought me up on charges or
marched against the article it was other
students who had never met so you know
which is to say it's not all students
and that's something that gets you know
forgotten it's a cadre of activists so
on the word grad students run this it
was two guys who brought me up on title
nine complaints there has been this
protest march before that against the
first essay which I think was largely
undergrads so I mean as far as the
metaphors I mean this is something I've
been thinking about and trying to puzzle
up because I do think there's this
growing climate of sexual paranoia on
campus that is fueled these title nine
like inquisitions partly because is you
know people probably know the federal
government the Department of Education
dictates that colleges and universities
have to conduct these tribunals on
campus but to try to minimize or lower
sexual assault and create a you know
atmosphere on campus of gender equity so
they're you know our good reasons
behind this and everybody does near the
sexual-assault has been a problem and
often times in unaddressed problems so
just to say to all that but um and you
your piece and look at the first piece
of the Chronicle of Higher Education it
was basically you were reflecting on
your experience as an undergrad and a
grad student and kind of a loser sexual
morality on campus between students and
professors are just more broadly so how
did people you know I mean how could
they get upset at that in in the sense
of somehow than you being on their
campus was threatening yeah well part of
the problem is I tend toward irony and
you're not supposed to be ironic about
these things so there has been this new
regulation prohibiting professors and
students from dating I mean even if they
were in different departments or
different schools or different campuses
so I thought that one too far because
you know we already had regulations
against non-consensual sex but this was
prohibiting consensual relationships
which to my mind was addressed at women
and at impeding women from doing things
they might want to do is like a
protectionist I mean I called it
feminist paternalism and around the same
time there was this all the stuff about
trigger warnings going on and so I was
writing about this at mature of
regulation that I thought was really in
sanitizing students as opposed to
promoting their ability to function in
the world you know after graduation as a
feminist is it was it infantilizing all
students or was it specifically kind of
denying sexual agency to female students
well they're written in gender-neutral
language but yes of course they're aimed
at women and it's mostly women who are
filing the complaints about this stuff
and to go back to the McCarthyism or the
witch-hunt kind of metaphors part of
what's happening is that while we know
that sexual assault is a problem the
definition of sexual assault is being
expanded and expanded and expanded
behind closed doors so that when I ended
up writing about this title 9 in cases
mine and I got all of this information
about other people's cases around the
country they were being brought up on
charges for things like making what
somebody thought was a sexual joke
campus bar or eye contact that somebody
thought was like the wrong kind of eye
contact so even like micro behaviors you
know jokes are starting to be subject to
policing by campus regulators whose
budgets increased and whose power
increases the more stuff they fund to
regulate and adjudicate a lot of us had
to do was a Dear Colleague letter that
was put out a few years ago under the
Obama administration under title 9 which
guarantees equal access to education any
any programs that are funded by federal
dollars that said universities have to
investigate any claim of sexual
harassment or sexual assault and lowered
the standard of what counts as guilt why
was that changed why was it
reinterpreted in that particular way
yeah so you're talking about
preponderance of evidence which is a
much lower standard it's like 50/50 plus
a feather that's how I've described as
opposed to say clear and convincing
which is higher and you know I'm not a
lawyer but my understanding is that's
the bar of proof maybe in other kinds of
tort cases I'm not entirely sure but one
of the things that's happening also is
that it's up to these individual title 9
investigators who act as I've learned in
this very capricious manner in terms of
deciding what preponderance is and in
fact I just heard an interesting study
by a guy at UCLA who has kind of modeled
or predicted the false conviction rate
under the preponderance standard as
upward of 20%
so the lower the standard of proof the
higher the false conviction rate
basically well you talk about and and
you talk about it in a long chapter
which is fascinating and then also come
back to it in your coda which is
subtitled eyewitness to a witch trial
it's a chapter about how how an OU
became or how it yes became in now years
after the fact and you talk about a
professor Ludlow can you quick you know
summarize that case for us and then
let's talk about some of the
implications yeah I should say I didn't
know this professor and I wrote a couple
paragraphs about his case in the
original sexual paranoia article that I
wrote in that was partly why I got
brought up on the title nine charges
because I had used this phrase dating I
said he had dated a former graduate
student because I had read a court
filing of his and he was I mean this was
known on campus he had a well not all
that was known I mean I've played or
found out a lot after I was asked by him
to be his faculty support person in his
dismissal hearing and he ended up giving
me all the files in his case because
strangely her in a quirk he had not
signed a confidentiality agreement in
all of the law so he could actually kind
of talk more freely not so much even a
quirk as that student protest meant that
the university retracted a settlement
agreement that was in the works and so
peel up without any settlement or
confidentiality agreement but so he had
had a consensual three-month
relationship with a graduate student in
his department and I know it was
consensual because when he turned over
all this material part of what he had
was transcripts and records of like 2000
emails and text messages from this
three-month relationship when I read all
of it
it's clear that it was consensual and
it's even clear that she had the upper
hand in the relationship that the
accusation was that he had misused his
power and you know what that doesn't
account for is that they're different
kinds of power there's institutional
power there's other kinds of power
there's the power of who's more love
with who who's younger and more
attractive you know there's all sorts of
power at work here anyway so that was
part of the case so but then he ended up
getting in trouble for an incident with
an undergraduates too so he had gone out
for an evening drinking and going to
galleries with a former student of his
who had invited him to go to an art
event and she wasn't his dude
it should say there was no of code at
the time against professors and students
going out and you know I do say in my
own education which was in art schools
and a different era
you know professors and students went
out drinking in all sorts of things all
the time so that would have been no big
deal but maybe in the last I don't know
five eight years ten years it's the
atmosphere on campus has changed and
this is part of the paranoia story or I
think professors and male professors are
increasingly being seen as predators
really and as always on the verge of
misusing their power for illicit you
know gain particularly the sexual nature
women are passive and at the mercy of
this you know crew predatory professors
so this really instill traits into how
any incident like this is seen and
probably I think into the students own
perceptions of what happens to them
so he loved oh and this undergrad went
out drinking just various art events and
bars she ended up sleeping his place
they didn't have sex they were both
clothed they were sleeping on top of the
comforter a few days later she said she
tried to kill herself by jumping into
Lake Michigan in February because she
was so upset about what she said it
happened between them she said he had
groped her he said he didn't that she
had come unto him he said she said he
came on her so it's you know it was a
huge she's that thing but it can't you
know in campus terms he was pretty much
automatically guilty when you do an
incredible close reading of the
administrator who actually was in charge
of adjudicating this and you say it's I
mean it's totally whimsical on that
storage there's no way he was going to
be found anything other than responsible
yeah and in my view and I have to
emphasize this is my opinion right there
was a lot of gender bias and there was
very capricious you know reasoning where
in a couple of cases she found in his
favor but in other cases she found
against him and in both cases the you
know there was no evidence supporting
the control
so yeah it's hard to see how she got
there I think about my own undergraduate
I graduated college in 85 I have
graduate degrees from the lady at 90 and
96 there were a lot of lecherous
professors who were constantly you know
asking girls out etcetera is is that a
problem and you know and and if it is
then how do you regulate it and we're
not regulated but how do you deal with
it and we're not talking about rapist
here we're not talking about people but
you know just kind of lecherous people
yeah what is the way to to deal with
that if it's an issue I would say the
way is education and frank discussions I
mean I do think we're doing a terrible
job of educating students about these
kinds of realities and yeah I you know
obviously think nobody in a position
power over a student's career or grading
that person should be watching after
them you know I also think that students
have to be educated in limit students
particularly to deal with these kinds of
situations because they come up all the
time in life I mean life is full of
power and hierarchical you know
differences between people and you know
you can regulate away and I I myself
think there's probably something about
human sexuality there's always going to
evade all attempts to regulate it so I
think you have to deal with these
situations kind of as they evolve and
obviously the problem is not just
professors its students and students
particularly in situations involving
alcohol which I talk about a lot so
education is the answer to this
you talk about your feminism in the book
and you know and also that it's kind of
ironic and we ran an excerpt of the book
at recent calm and you know it's it's
ironic for you because you're you're a
woman of the left or you're on the left
your political commitments on the left
and the people who are supporting you
tend to be more on the libertarian side
of things or the libertarian right how
has feminism changed over your
professional career we're at various
points if you go back to maybe the late
sixties there was a flowering of kind of
sexual empowerment of women then there
was people like Susan Brown Miller and
talking about again straight you know
where the idea that all almost all
heterosexual intercourse was was a form
of rape one way or the other because you
couldn't escape patriarchy then it you
know it kind of its wobbled around since
then what has changed in feminism and
how can it what is a good feminist
response to sexual paranoia that we
ultimately treats women has you know
with that agency or not fully in control
of their sexual desire that was a lot of
questions man yeah I mean yes I'm
finding myself in strange company you
know and a lot of that's on the civil
liberties and due process side of things
because you've got students who consider
themselves to be activists and I suppose
would think of themselves as on the Left
I maybe have some questions about that
who are acting like conservatives are
acting and you've got conservatives
acting like liberals you've got these
students you know being increasingly
less authoritarian and really willing to
you know throughout free speech and due
process and that kind of stuff so I'm
still trying to figure this out these
sort of anti-democratic tendencies well
a definitely ante free speech yes I mean
I would say for expert I go so far as to
say any democratic but in terms of the
feminism of the moment on campus I mean
I'm also saying this is feminist
conservatism and so I know the right I
stunned ugh right-wing talk-show radio
host like in conversation when I said
this is you know conservatism this sort
of feminist protectionism and he
couldn't grasp that concept because the
right has instilled in some of their
minds that you know this can only be
this form of leftism so the people
you're talking about in the 80s I guess
when a bunch of religion go Angela
yeah and feminists were trying to ban
pornography certainly feminist okay so
that's the point is it certain feminists
you know mostly of affiliated with
Andrea Dworkin and Catherine MacKinnon
who are the anti-pornography
rafi feminism Brahm Miller maybe would
be sort of more in that camp who did
make alliances with the right and it was
a puritanical and I think conservative
form of feminism so the point to make
you know if to be if maybe to say it
simply is you have to say feminism's
rural so I would call myself you know
like a leftist emancipatory you know
oriented semanas psychoanalytic I would
have a certain points call myself a
Marxist feminism so um you know that's
like to sometimes myself you know here
in the company of Reason or getting
calls from the Cato Institute you know
it's surprising I mean I'm trying to
figure it out
and I also you know what I don't want to
participate in with the libertarian
slash conservative crowd is the feminist
bashing but what I want to do is reclaim
a kind of feminism or revise and you
know keep what's useful or what um I
think leading us toward you know
something more like liberation on
autonomy and equality and that kind of
stuff within a kind of libertarian
genealogy of ideas there's there's a
strong feminist component and its people
like Rose Wilder Lane it was the
daughter of Laura Ingalls Wilder and is
widely credited with died a milder yet
with writing or editing she was
professional writer editing the little
and looks Isabelle Patterson who was a
well-known book reviewer obviously
people like I'm Rand who is you know I
would would not be feminist but is
individualís and there's a tradition in
the nineteenth century kind of
individualist autonomous feminism and
autonomy is certainly uh you know a big
concept for for libertarians do you is
that a way forward for feminism - I mean
if it's focusing on autonomy more than
you know intersectional elements of
where you know well it's actually it's
race a class that our moral or power
positions relatively speaking because
one and I guess I'll stop talking yeah
any questions while I got well it's you
know one of the one of the weird thing
is wedding feminist scholars and this
happens line I think it's happening with
intersectional feminism they put the
gender aspect last because there's like
oh now you know what actually race or
class is more important well I don't
think class is even figured in you know
when the students are talking about
intersectional feminism look I respect
this commitment to racial justice with
student activists but it you know be
difficult to untangle the genealogy of
all this I mean yeah I do veer toward
maybe it was reading I was going to say
tort ideas about autonomy maybe it was
reading a lot Laura Ingalls Wilder as a
child who was a big influence on me but
you know I maybe would leave behind the
Marxist feminist and say something like
democratic socialist feminist with an
emphasis on the democratic which I think
maybe pushes me more toward a liberal
kind of you and I mean there is a
certain kind of overlap with the
liberalism of libertarians on such
things as free speech and in due process
I suppose so they are these tangled
lineages I mean I suppose where we
depart is more on the economic side
where I would be somebody favoring more
government control and economic justice
and redistribution and that kind of
stuff so that's you know where I'm
trying to sort through my alliances with
you guys right so in terms of feminism
wait did I answer it or not well yeah
where where what what is a positive
feminism that you would like to see kind
of become dominant on campus and and
you're right you know it's not if you
know even in the 80s or whatever it
wasn't all feminists we're you know man
haters or they're all this or that but
what is what's a positive vision of
feminism that you would like to see kind
of become resurgent right now well I you
know I think there isn't a model really
I mean there was when I was coming up a
kind of left wing or materialist or
Marxist feminism it was very interesting
to me to talk about stuff like you know
talk much more of a class and and pay
for housework and you know things like
that just the material issues
so things like you know can women own
property can women probably I've even
settled that one a while ago yeah no no
but I'm saying these are materialist
questions of you know is stunning that
women single women couldn't get birth
control prescriptions yeah pills until
1973 and an abortion obviously also big
issues yeah huge and yeah so I mean the
first wave I you know settled a lot of
that stuff to get us the vote that kind
of thing you know which is why I think
feminism has been this historically
crucial important world-changing
movement I mean you know just the fact
of women only property or having
economic autonomy you know I mean I
think people forget how recently that
wasn't the case so it's why I can't kind
of join in the feminist bashing and why
I also don't think equity feminism goes
far enough like just focusing on pay
issues because I think there really are
entrenched gender differentials and
partly I mean it goes maybe a bit
off-topic for you but you know within
the context of heterosexual femininity I
think a lot of women me included I know
this firsthand are very just simply um
self sabotaging I think femininity in
itself has got a lot of pathological
elements and that's kind of where the
campus stuff to me is veering it
reinforces a traditional femininity
that's these women as needing protection
she's women sexuality as something
that's endangering to them I mean part
of the concept that is I can prevailing
in this on campus is this idea of trauma
and trauma studies has been a huge thing
and this idea I also got in trouble for
being a bit not deferential enough to
this term survivor you know you've got
people who have a you know kind of an
uncomfortable sexual experience on a
date calling themselves survivors and
pressing complaint and again not in them
minimize campus assault not to minimize
kind of crappy stuff that guys do when
they're drunk and you know have a
drunken woman in there
you know sites so all that being said I
also do think in terms of autonomy and I
talked about this in the book women have
to take more responsibility for stuff
like passing out drunk in places that
are dicey and it doesn't mean you asked
to get assaulted but it means if you're
at if you're saying a guy is responsible
for his behavior when he's drunk I also
think women have to be pragmatically
self protective when you know Joe Biden
recently just this week said all drunk
cite all drunk sex is rape is that a
farcical statement well then basically
all sex is rape and on campus because I
mean there's a lot of kids I had a
conversation with Susie bright the sex
activists and she said she talks to kids
who've never had so respects and
encourages it for them but you know
Biden is talking about criminalizing a
vast proportion of the sex on campus and
that in fact is what's happened that the
rules and the codes have been rewritten
behind closed doors such that almost all
sex can be charged as something criminal
particularly those charges go against
men and I say this as a feminist that
you know if two people are drunk they're
both responsible for the sex that takes
place not just the guys and and I mean
just to underscore you're not talking
about if somebody is passed out yeah
it's like they can't consent that's
right like we're not talking about that
we're dying about people who might be
tipsy or have been flirting or even are
in a relationship but retro actively
things complete definitions can change
yeah that happens and the problem with
the some of these cases it is very hard
to adjudicate because there's you know
he said she said and yes I do think a
guy who has sex with an unconscious
woman is a you know can be brought up on
criminal charges of rape but that
shouldn't happen on campus because that
is a criminal
and do you think that it would it be
helpful if these cases were moved off of
the campus and put into the actual
criminal justice system which also has
you know its own problems in dealing
with sexual so you know that also is the
important thing to say that a lot of
what's happening on campus and is an
overcorrection to what didn't happen
previously in the criminal justice
system where sexual assault was
trivialized or you know you couldn't get
a case of brought forward by a DA or
took years for it to go forward so the
campus system was meant to address that
but I think it's doing it in a sexually
so you know we've talked a little bit
about kind of how feminism has changed
and where it might go what in your
experience I mean as you've been
teaching college students for years what
what happened to students because this
on a certain level and I can say from my
undergraduate years I can see the
trajectory where it ends up here but on
things like speech I don't remember in
the in at least in the first half of the
80s I don't remember a student protest
that was insisting on the last speech it
was always you know pushing back against
the stuffed shirt so we're trying to
shut things down now that seems to be
very different in them with sexuality
you know where where is this coming from
I mean you have to say on campus there's
like really two very contradictory
stories about sex because you know you
do have this prevailing hookup culture
and I should say you know I teach film
and so my students are oftentimes making
films and writing screenplays about
their own lives and we talk about this
stuff and so I do think I find out
pretty much what's going on so there's
that side the hookup culture and then
there's this other side which is let's
be not a suck-up culture you know as I
think we're both baby boomers and you
know people were having more sex yes
they do yeah Millennials have less sex
than Gen Xers have less sex than baby
boomers and the Greatest Generation
never had sex but that's their problem
wait they're saying they're having less
sex yeah yeah on campus I mean my survey
show that sexual activity both up to
high school level and it's college
levels actually lowers interest and is
it you
where I guess that would be a different
question but where does that come from
but you have a sense of what's going on
I think I have some sense of what's
going on and you know people are never
great self reporters about their own sex
lives but you know I hear how they talk
about sex let's say and it's it's all
very open Pro sex there's a lot of you
know discussion about alternative
practices and stuff you know they're
very knowledgeable about about all of
this stuff but I do think there is a
kind of Puritanism as well and this
sense of potential trauma harm I don't
know where it comes from you know I'm
somebody who doesn't like to recycle
used up cliches and so all this stuff is
out helicopter parenting and coddled
students I don't know I can't you know I
don't want to recycle that stuff but yes
there definitely is a change I mean it's
a huge change from our generation to
this generation of students and I think
in a certain way it actually has maybe
something to do with the being best
friends with your parents and never
having gone through this real rebellion
against Authority and so they're sort of
you know calling their parents of you
know two or three times a day and never
really left home and not even shouting
at them yeah you're kind of to say I
hate you know they're best besties you
do you know you use Freudian analysis
what is what's going on there them
because this is like a radical shift
from what 50 or 100 years ago would have
been taken as a universal thing that you
individuate yourself against your
parents and that you struggle to be
independent from them and we seem to be
witnessing it and I say this as a parent
you know a much more kind of fraternal
bond with your children rather than
almost an adversarial yeah well here's
something I've been speculating that and
don't have an answer to but maybe you do
I mean when I was coming of age there
was not the same panic about
intergenerational sex so the professor
student question was killed a lot of
women I knew some men you know had
relationships with
professors when my best friend married
his French professor he was like a
sophomore so you know did he stop does
he speak French very well so you know
this this panic on campus about the
professor students being I mean I think
it's almost related to this question of
the best friends and you know there's
something going on about generations I'm
not a smart enough Freudian to answer it
but I do see some how this stuff is
related to itself or each other however
you would put that I don't have the
answer yet I'll get back to you on that
well the trauma you know kind of the
trauma and the and again without the
demeaning people who went through
horrible experiences but the kind of
fetishization of survivorship where do
you think that's coming from because I
can remember I guess it was Christopher
lashes the minimal self which is you
know it's a Frankfurt School influenced
thesis about kind of Marxist Freudian
theory about you know and he was writing
in like 1980 I think for that about
fetishizing survivorship and that people
were appropriating you know stories
about concentration camps he lit into
Betty Ford and for calling he saying
that being a suburban housewife in the
late 50s was the equivalent of being in
a concentration camp and that that has
preceded a pace is you know is that
where the the kind of trauma culture is
coming from or where is it that we are
so worried that our children are you
know there are effectively no real
threats to kids anymore in terms of you
know they don't start they don't have
childhood diseases very few get abducted
they go to school longer you know but
we're acting as if you know if they see
one image you know they're going to be
ruined for life is this you know where
does this come from I mean I think a lot
of it would have to do was identity
politics and you know I'm not somebody
who's going to rant about identity
politics because it's often it's been
very important that my students have
been
notice I mean really schooled in a kind
of multicultural curriculum they're very
attentive to all forms of injustice to
marginalization they're you know really
I think deeply committed and you know in
an honest way talk to including this
range of experiences that have been
marginalized into the mainstream you
know and they're great about that and
and you know very self-aware of their
own participations and you know forms of
privilege and hierarchy and that kind of
thing so another side of that though is
that um you know the the traumatic
experience or the person who's you know
on the margin I mean that that position
is sort of the privileged one in campus
politics at the moment and I suppose
some people might blame that on leftist
and leftist professors and that kind of
thing um perhaps but you know I think
these these things are related yeah well
that's a Dave Chappelle the comedian
causes the misery Olympics which might
be yeah a really Archer he's in a
position where he can say that I'm not
sure that I would um what has been the
reaction among your colleagues and among
your students because she said it wasn't
your students who you know protested you
but you know what kind of response have
you gotten as you explored this material
and it's right you know when you talk
about irony in the book is very I don't
want to say it's funny it's not laugh at
look but it's very ironic it's very wry
and clearly humor has you know on campus
it's hard to be funny these days and
there's Chappell is one Jerry Seinfeld
Bill Maher a number of comedians that
said they don't even play colleges
anymore but how have your colleagues and
have your immediate students kind of
responded to your material I should say
a little bit about how I'm an anomalous
kind of person which is helpful and
probably how I got myself into this
situation you know I didn't go to
university I went to art schools I
started out as a painter and then a
video artist and I ended up teaching in
a university teaching film because I was
a filmmaker but I don't do that anymore
I actually write these books so I've
always had a bit one foot on
but off of campus so it does allow me to
be both an insider you know I think this
book could have only been written by an
insider and the criticisms I've made but
you know also bit of an outsider too and
yeah I think more ironic about a lot of
the stuff so it's been interesting to
have this as my material and it's almost
like the academic novel or satire that
I've always wanted to write but didn't
so on my campus I think um people are
sort of terrified actually and don't say
anything so after I got marched on and I
wrote about the title nine things my
students didn't say a word I mean
they're kind of great about it and it
one time said to some students I was
close to how come nobody ever brought up
this protest march thing she said oh we
knew about it Laura you know and I've
had very few colleagues at Northwestern
weigh in to me even over about the
articles that I wrote and exposing the
title nine stuff much more response from
people around the country so I don't
know if it said it's the Midwest and
everybody's very polite I can't really
answer so you know you talk about
paranoia McCarthyism the Salem witch
trials
you know the Salem witch trials was a
classic case of hysteria
Samuel Sewell one of the judges ended
his life wearing sackcloth and ashes to
pay penance for what he did is this
bubble going to burst or I mean do you
see any sign of that that people are
kind of regaining a more more measured
sense of where we should be on campus
well though interesting parallel is that
you've got these accusations made by
teenage girls or you know in Salem and
similarly often times here I you know I
don't to be grandiose I hope this book
makes some difference
partly I hope that it means that people
who have been through these kinds of
inquisitions or processes are willing to
come forward and talk about their
stories you know what really is
happening is a lot of this is ending up
in the civil courts where undergrad men
who've been accused of things that they
say
didn't do or the circumstances were more
murky these cases are ending up in
courts and it's going to be civil judges
that I think turn back the tide of these
over prosecutions and in fact it's
really interesting case at Brandeis with
two men students where the after a
breakup one guy said that the other guy
had kissed him while he was asleep and
that was sexual assault because he
couldn't consent and this judge who
wrote a really kind of eloquent decision
more or less said are you kidding me you
know because the sorry the what they
call the special examiner at Brandeis
that was their terms but some think it
was what they called him or her had
ruled that this was indeed assault
because the guy was asleep and couldn't
give consent so the judge is very
eloquent decision I think will have some
effect in other cases like that so I
think that's what where it's going to
end up and of course your book having in
your experience and speaking about it
particularly because you're on the left
and a feminist that is it's kind of a
shot across the bow right of saying you
know you're not you know you're you're
not rush limbaugh you know decrying the
sort of absolutely yeah and I was in a
position that I could come forward
because I'm tenured I'm at a research
university that does support academic
freedom despite what happened to me I
mean that's a complicated sort of issue
in terms of who greenlit those charges I
think but I think the problem is that
you know like about half the posts
aureate now is a not tenure-track
they're on a contract those people
wouldn't have a chance in hell of coming
forward writing an article as I did in
fact if you get brought up on some kind
of even specious complaint you're likely
to lose your job I mean I've seen that
happen and know a couple of lawsuits
that are going forward so um you know
partly because I expose the kinds of
stuff I've written about I've written
about scandal I've written about sexual
politics I was a guest a bit more
willing to kind of go out on some some
limbs about it than other people with it
well I'm glad that you did the book is
unwanted advances
sexual paranoia comes to campus the
author is Laura Kipnis thanks so much
for talking to us of richly reported and
you know fascinating great so thank you
very much thanks for reason I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]